[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the left would very much
like you to stop talking and thinking
about bad decisions they've made over
the years that they happen to be
profiting from shut up they're screaming
including to this show obviously we
won't and you shouldn't either details
in a minute but first two weeks from New
Year's and the Trump administration is
trying one last time to get funding for
that promised border wall on our
southern border the president says he's
willing to shut down the government in
order to get the first five billion in
construction money over the weekend
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
promised that will never happen under
any circumstances President Trump should
understand there are not the votes for
the wall in the house or the Senate he
is not going to get the wall in any form
he is not gonna get the wall notice the
pronoun Schumer used Heat Donald Trump
cannot have his wall says the Senate
Minority Leader but what about the rest
of us the other 325 million people who
live here turns out we can't have a wall
either wall it's just too expensive
in fact it's wasteful says and brace
yourself now for an icy blast of comedy
here the Democratic Party I asked the
people at Customs and Border Protection
what would it cost to have scanners to
scan all the vehicles coming in they
said 300 million dollars that's a far
cry from five billion a much more
effective way to have a secure border
most of us are speaking for myself
consider the wall immoral ineffective
inexpensive to spend billions of dollars
on an immoral ineffective and expensive
wall
don't waste billions of dollars of
taxpayer money in order to build
something that will not make our border
more secure water security is enormous
ly important but I think building a wall
is a very costly and inefficient way to
do that
o so mister math guy Bernie Sanders says
if border wall is quote very costly okay
how costly is it precisely get your
calculator out here are the numbers the
estimated cost
of a border wall is about 25 billion
dollars it's estimated so let's say it's
twice that that would still be a tiny
fraction of the price of the pointless
stalemate we're now waging in
Afghanistan that cost about forty five
billion every year not even including of
course the vast human cost now compare
that to the twenty five billion needed
to restore national sovereignty with the
wall
hmm and yet and this is strange nobody
in Washington seems to be upset about
the price of the Afghanistan debacle a
lot of people here are getting rich from
it and maybe that's the difference
you also hear endlessly and usually from
people who live in gated communities
that walls just don't work but if that's
true if they really don't work then why
has Congress been happy to help pay for
border barriers in Jordan Tunisia and
Israel Nancy Pelosi says that walls are
immoral and yet for some reason she's
not flying to Jerusalem to lecture the
Israelis on how they're wasting US aid
building walls it don't work Israelis
know how effective walls are that's why
they have them israel's wall on the
Egyptian border almost completely halted
illegal immigration from that country in
fact by some measures completely not one
person came over at once they made it
taller turns out there is a limit to the
height of ladders the truth as you know
and as usual is precisely the opposite
of what they're telling you the Left
fears our border wall precisely because
it would work and could keep working
long after President Trump leaves office
and that is why when pressed invariably
they fall back on their signature
argument racism border walls are racist
the president went to the heart of what
I call his Brown Menace theory these
migrants they're dirty people they bring
disease this border wall thing is about
controlling the Browning of America
Donald Trump is fixated on the southern
border as he was the day that he
announced this campaign it is not about
securing the borders it is about
xenophobic racist bigoted beliefs he
believes and unfortunately maybe the
facts will bear this out his base is
scared of anyone who is not visibly
white his bases
Aird they always say that they're scared
the right they cling to things for
comfort
it's just projection look around who's
angry who's yelling who's hysterical the
left permanent Washington and their
servants in the media they're the ones
who are terrified
they don't want an honest debate about
immigration or a lot of other mindless
policies they've been benefiting from
for many years they hate Trump for
forcing a debate on any of this they
hate you for agreeing with him tough